welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series and get the free bonus
companion worksheets that go with this
video check the link in the description
below alright today is day 12 and we're
gonna learn how you can overcome your
stress if somebody is we're mentioning
earlier somebody's really stressed out
they're not stressed out for no reason
it's because they're focusing on
something that makes them feel stressed
they often when they're focusing on it
that changes the body you start to feel
tight you start to feel a certain way
and then they use language like I don't
know what to do why am I so overwhelmed
so three things control you feel every
moment what you focus on what you do
with your body if your shoulders are
down if your breathing are high it's not
hard to figure out you're not gonna be
in a very resourceful state if I take
that same person I change their bodies
radically I get him to talk at a
different tempo I get them to move their
body differently I've taught this for
what 41 years three years ago at Harvard
they did study on power postures where
they showed that if you stand like this
with your hands on your hips like
Superman or Wonder Woman or if you lean
back like this like the guy is an
obnoxious at the office and do this and
it literally changes your testosterone
by 25 percent within two minutes it
reduces cortisol which you know is the
stress hormone by 30 percent and you're
33% more likely to take an action so if
we change what we focus on if we change
the way we use our body FLE change our
language patterns will instantly feel
different thing that's how people use
their body when they're worried versus
when they're excited if you learn to use
your body first use your focus first
you can literally change out any final
moments and then you develop new habits
where you start to feel good all the
time and it isn't some phony fake pumpup
it's literally the way you've
conditioned your body just like being
fit as an athlete you want to be
emotionally fit as I said 70% of the
time people live in stress and living in
stress is living in survival now all
organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know a deer gets
chased by a pack of coyotes when it out
runs the Coyotes it goes back to grazing
and the event is over and the definition
of stress is when your brain and body
are knocked out of balance out of
homeostasis the stress response is what
the body and Nate Lee does
to return itself back to order so you're
driving down the road someone cuts you
off you jam on the brakes you may give
them the finger and then you settle back
down then the event is over and boom now
everything's back back to normal but
what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you outside the cave but
what if it's your coworker sitting right
next to you and all day long you're
turning on those chemicals because
they're pushing all your emotional
buttons when you turn on the stress
response and you can't turn it off now
you're headed for a disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that extended period of time
it's a scientific fact that the hormones
of stress down regulate genes and create
disease long-term affects human beings
because of the size of the neocortex we
can turn on the stress response just by
thought alone look I think about our
problems and turn on those chemicals
that means them our thoughts could make
us sick so if it's possible that our
thoughts could make us sick is it
possible that our thoughts could make us
well the answer is absolutely yes so
then what are the emotions that are
connected to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry pain
suffering guilt shame unworthiness the
envy jealousy those are all created by
the hormones of stressin and psychology
calls them normal human states of
consciousness I call those altered
states of consciousness so then we tend
to remember those traumatic events more
because in survival you better be ready
if it happens again that's and in one's
survival gene is switched on you could
have ten really great things that happen
to you in your day and you just have one
bad thing that happens and you cannot
take your attention off that bad that
that unhappy thing because survival
genus which thought many years ago after
the DNA helix was discovered by Watson
and Crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
turns out less than 5% more like 1% of
glommit planet are born with a genetic
condition like type 1 diabetes or
tay-sachs disease or sickle cell anemia
the other 95 to 99 percent are created
by lifestyle and by choices you can take
two identical twins exact same genome
one dies at 51 the other one dies at 85
same gene different environment so all
of a sudden they said we lied that was
wrong it's not genes that create disease
it's the environment that signals the
gene that creates disease well ok but
that's not the whole truth too because
you could have two people working side
by side in the same Factory one gets
cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all so there must be some internal
order that would cause one person to not
get it while another one does so is it
possible then if the environment signals
the gene and it does and the end product
of an experience in the environment is
called an emotion can you signal the
gene ahead of the environment by
embracing an elevated emotion we've done
the research on this where we measured
7500 different gene expressions in a
group of people it came to an advanced
event for four days and we had them
doing a seated meditation a walking
meditation a laying down meditation a
standing meditation and at the end of
four days just four days the common
eight genes that were upregulated two
genes to suppress cancer cells and tumor
growth two genes for neurogenesis the
growth of new neurons in response to
novel experiences and learning the gene
that signals stem cells to go to damaged
areas and repair them the gene for
oxidative stress who is upregulated we
started seeing all these genes that are
very very healthy to cause the body to
flourish imagine if people were doing
that for three months we also measured
telomeres the little shoestrings on the
end of DNA that tell us our biological
age we asked people to do the work
meditation five out of seven days for 60
days measure their telomeres that
determine their biological age
sixty days later 74 percent of the
people lengthen their telomeres 40%
significant change 20% a very remarkable
change that means that they got a little
bit of their life back if it lengthened
by 10%
they got 10% of their life back it turns
out that one of the best stress
relievers on the planet is something
that most of us don't ever do and that
is seek out time with friends when we
feel totally stressed out when you're
doing twice as much work as you normally
do or you're feeling twice as much
stress as you normally feel studies at
Harvard show that what you need is you
need to see your friends twice as much
now
Sean anchor is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
Harvard and he studied this phenomenon
he looked at at people that were
stressed at schools and in call centers
and in the military and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that there were the
most resilient the people that had the
best ability to deal with stress when
times got tough were the ones that saw
their friends the most it was the people
with the tightest social connections
that had the ability to weather the
storms that life throw at us I want you
to write down three people three people
that when you hang out with them you
feel energized that when you have plans
with them you're excited about seeing
them when this video ends reach out to
them that's right pick up the phone send
them a text I want you to invite them to
do something go out to lunch go for a
walk in the woods get a cup of coffee go
out to dinner even if you're not
stressed out I guarantee you at least
one of the three people that you're
going to reach out to needs you if you
have depression if you have anxiety if
you have post-traumatic stress disorder
if you have any kind of mental health
condition it's nothing to be ashamed of
and it's nothing to hide and it's
something to hit head-on with there's
one thing one thing that if you did
every single day no joke it would make
an extraordinary difference in whatever
mental health issue you're struggling
with and that is exercise and the reason
why I say this is not based on
personal experience it's based on the
fact that the I think it's the American
Psychiatric Association this is coming
from dr. John Ratey a friend of mine who
has written a ton of books about not
only ADHD but also the benefits of
exercise and what it has on your brain
but he's also a professor at Harvard and
a practicing clinician and this is his
area of expertise and one of the things
that they now mandate as a diagnosis for
anybody with depression or anxiety or
any mental illness frankly is you gotta
exercise every day and the reason you've
gotta exercise every day is because what
we know about human beings is that when
you physically move your physiology
changes and that changes your brain
getting your heart rate up getting
outside breathing feeling connected
getting out of your house which may make
you feel depressed and trapped doing
that every day that physical push you
don't have to run you don't have to go
to aerobics class class get outside with
your dog in the woods walk with a good
friend for two or three miles doing that
every single day not only moves your
body which changes your mind it gets you
out of your physical environment which
is one of the things that people with
depression tend to have a hard time
doing and it also creates a bit of
momentum and a bit of a routine in your
life you take on just that single thing
get outside and exercise every single
day as if your life depends upon it
because you know what it does your brain
needs it your body needs it your mental
health needs it there's been thousands
and hundreds of thousands and millions
of warriors that have been in very
stressful situations faced evil and face
death much worse than the situation I'm
in or urine that we might consider
stressful and I even did this when I was
overseas when I was on deployment when I
was a combat leader I was feeling stress
and you know what we took casualties and
it was awful it was heartbreaking and
but there were other soldiers and
warriors throughout time that have been
in much worse situations Gettysburg or
vicksburg or the Battle of the Bulge and
in all those horrible situations they
proved really that humans can withstand
almost most unimaginable stress which
meant to me that I could - and you can
and the first step for me is doing that
taking that look to gain some
perspective and then in order to gain
perspective you got to do something that
we already talked about you've got to
detach you've got to detach from the
problems or the stress that you're
experiencing so that you can get that
perspective of them now there's a couple
different types of stress now if it's
something that you can control that's
causing you stress well why aren't you
getting control of it now there's also
stress that's caused by things that you
cannot control and if you remember
talking earlier about artillery and how
horrible that was and what made it so
horrible was that there's no control
over so if you can't control something
and you can't get control of it you have
to at least embrace what you can and I'm
not saying you're gonna embrace
artillery shelling but I'll tell you
what when it comes to things like
artillery or for us in Ramadi was IEDs
and we could do everything we could do
to mitigate that risk but eventually
there's only so much you can do and you
cannot completely eliminate it
but you can't control it so why you
gonna worry about it why are you gonna
stress about it if there's something
that's completely beyond your control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it and on top of that if it's something
that you can't control how can you look
at it in a different light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of a lie you know the the chaos of
combat is something that I couldn't
control but I had to embrace it so I
could try and figure out how to take
advantage of it so when it comes to
stress don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it use it use
it to make yourself sharper and more
alert and use it to make yourself think
more and learn more and get better and
use that stress as a catalyst to make
yourself better if you want to learn to
deal with stress put yourself in
stressful situations that are under some
kind of control you know even something
like paintball you know we do gigs and
echelon front when we put people through
what we call ft X's where you go out and
you're gonna fire we usually use airsoft
because it's a little bit more it's a
little easier to work with but actually
what we started using now is we've got
these high-end laser tag guns and so
that's that's what we use and they are
super effective they're they're they're
awesome they're awesome training tools
like if we would have had him if we
would have if they would have existed
when I was in the SEAL Teams I would
have used them that because they're that
good
so we use those and we put people in
stressful situations go hit this target
there's bad guys you know people are
gonna get shot there's people yelling
put yourself in stress from stressful
situations and learn to detach put
yourself in stressful situations with
the purpose
of learning to detach and stepping back
mentally to figure out what's going on I
think the first thing we must all do at
some point in our maturity is decide not
to be a stress case you know there has
to be an intentional decision at some
point in our lives where we say look I'm
not gonna be the stressed anymore I'm
allowing too much stress into my life
and please notice the words I'm using
here I'm allowing too much stress into
my life most stress is not going to go
real no one hands you a plate of stress
it's not something you see and we can
transact an exchange it's something we
make up in our mind we make things
stressful that may or may not be or have
any cause to be stress inducing you know
one thing that could stress you out
might not be a stressful thing to
anybody else so that proves we're making
it up and since we're making it up we
should decide what we're gonna do in the
future or are we going to always be
stressful people or not I know that
sounds so silly but I made that decision
when I was young I was 20 years old and
I said look I don't want to be a
stressful person anymore
I used to stress about getting
everything right and getting good grades
I I'd stress about you know pleasing
people and stress about did I fit in I'd
stress about college that's stress about
and some ways that all this is made up
you know matter of fact most stress is
coming from usually one of two things
first is a false time crunch that we
perceive we think we only have so much
time so everything becomes stressed oh
my god I gotta get this done I gotta get
this done I got this done and we're
reacting our lives to really false
deadlines someone asks you for something
you think you have to get it to them
right away
you probably don't it's probably not a
real deadline and unless you ask them
when is the real deadline on this I mean
the point in which everything crumbles
and falls apart if you don't get it then
what would happen what does the worst
thing that would happen to beating it at
that exact time I'm crazy about this in
my life
if someone says well Brenda I need this
by Thursday I say okay if you need it by
Thursday is is Thursday the day every
would explode and fall apart if you
didn't get it they're like no I mean no
Monday would be fine and I just bought
myself Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
and part of day Monday
I just bought five days by asking when
the real deadline is because most people
they say they want something from you
when they want it not when they need it
so your job to help deal with just the
time crunch that stress can feel like is
asking when is the real deadline and all
these things that you're stressed out
about do they really need to be handled
right now this immediate second would it
be okay if you've created a plan and you
handle them over the next couple of days
next couple weeks next couple months
when you actually realize the
unbelievable amount of time we all have
as humans and how much more time we have
when we become focused diligent
intentional discipline then we're not so
much stressed anymore it's like I will
get to that when the time is appropriate
for that before that I've got other
things I created a method the components
are breathing mindset and coal exposure
gradual none forced cold exposure and
that's to optimize the mind-body
connection wim has figured out ways
namely through breath work and through
exposure to cold to take conscious
control over aspects of his physiology
that for most people they simply can't
tune into in control
[Music]
the cold my warm friend it brings about
a whole lot of more energy and that were
together with breathing makes you so
powerful but then you lose your wife and
a toll rumbles down for children art
worth for my wife and there was to be
with her forever she was the love of my
life she died she suicided
it's a it's a black hole within yourself
it breaks your heart and you don't know
why but the Train of a daily life is
going on and you gotta catch up
otherwise you lose it so I had to be
there for my children and yes we created
a new nest my children made me survive
in that time but nature yield my words
Nicole gave me a direct understanding of
deeper breathing and how to heal a
broken heart then I went did all kinds
of remarkable challenges apparently they
found it a very remarkable and great and
spectacular so came in contact with
television one after the other they
challenged me more more more more more
they go swim 50 meters under the ice go
swim 100 meters under the earth Clarke
Mount Everest ensures that ladder up
that the scientists became curious hey
what this man is doing is not possible
physiologically the science of what wim
HOF method does is one of the primary
interests of my lab now because it is so
powerful and it's been shown to be
powerful in the immune system we believe
it will also hold some real potential
for treatment of neurologic diseases and
this breathing technique brings you
right into the deepest part of our
physiology anybody can do it so you
become the alchemist of your own
chemistry peter entrepreneurs about
being a problem solver right your you
know what is selling selling is not
convincing selling is helping you know
as tech entrepreneurs here if you're
going to a customer whether it's
consumer or you're a b2b you know either
you're making your customers life easier
either you're reducing your stress where
you're making it harder and you're
increasing their stress I mean over the
years I think some of the things I've
come to learn trigger like dealer with
so many shark tank companies is one of
the greatest skill sets that an
entrepreneur employee salesperson can
have is reducing stress if you find that
when you go to work stress increases the
minute you walk in the door you've got a
problem if you have an employee and the
minute they walk in the door you have a
problem and they have a problem and what
I found is the best companies the
best employees that I have the best
investments that I have are the people
who reduce stress because those are the
people we don't want to give up you know
they may not they don't make the most
noise they don't always get the biggest
paychecks then always close the biggest
deals but when there's problems that
need to be solved they're already
working on them before you're even aware
of them those are the people that we
love and those are the things you know
reducing stress if you set in your mind
it goes as an entrepreneur for your
company 1 keeping your you know selling
and keeping your customers very happy to
stay ahead of the curve with your
competitors and 3 reducing stress of
everybody around you all your
stakeholders you're gonna be successful
because if you think about all your
personal experiences would you rather do
business with somebody who creates
stress or do you want to do business
with the person who reduces stress it's
easy answer but you'd be amazed at how
many people don't follow through enough
when I was growing up I had met my guru
when I was about 21 and I was going to
join his monastic order which was in
Hawaii I was at that time living in
Western Australia and studying in
university and I remembered my last year
of engineering I was feeling extremely
stressed I had a thesis which I've been
working on for a year and a half that I
needed to complete in the next month I
had seven or eight examinations that I
had to pass in order to graduate as an
engineer I was the president of the
youth group of our temple over that
local temple over there and
organizing a lot of different events and
I was also dancing as part of a dance
company that I was involved in and they
were also putting up a big show so we
were rehearsing almost every night and I
remember you nailing my guru saying
Gurudev I'm really stressed I have all
these things going on and I'm stressed
he emailed me back and I don't remember
the exact words that he he used but he
emailed me back and said the reason
you're stressed is because you don't
keep you awareness on one thing at a
time I'll be absolutely honest with you
ever since that they have never felt
stressed anymore and I know it's a very
bold Proclamation to make but it's true
because I clearly understood what he
said to me at that point whenever I was
dancing I was thinking about my thesis
and I was working on my thesis I was
thinking about the exams I had to do
when I was thinking on my exams when I
was studying for my exams I was thinking
about the youth group and wherever I was
I was thinking about something else
anxiety comes because we allow us to
drift away from the present moment and
go into the future or into the past in
an uncontrolled way so the past and the
future are not bad things as long as we
indulge in them or we enter them with
the aim to learn from them but we don't
if we just allow awareness to travel
into the past into the future all the
time it creates anxiety and we do that
because we're friend anxiety comes out
of a sense of fear where we allow lannis
to go into the future we create a
situation that hasn't happened we bring
it back into the present and start
living it as it has already happened
you keep repeating the process over and
over and over again you buildings I I'm
gonna get sick I'm gonna get sick you
think in the future what if I get sick
then what happens oh my god I'm gonna
get sick and then you've been back to
present and you start learning that five
minutes later you let your awareness go
into the future you think for yourself
I'm not gonna get better I'm gonna get
sick and then you bring away this back
into the present again and you start
worrying about it you keep repeating
this process over and over again and
you're billing tight so the way together
become stress and anxiety is to really
control where your hands goes every time
the awareness goes into the future into
the past and an uncontrolled way bring
it back to the present again and just do
this exercise being mindful of this
throughout the entire day
don't let your awareness go into the
past or into the future in an
uncontrolled way one of the things you
said is that it's good to kind of
explore your boundaries yeah when it
comes to fear this is something actually
that my meditation teacher has said to
me before and it made me realize I think
I need to get in there and start pushing
it a little bit in this in the tank
because it will help me in lots of areas
of my life because when you don't test
those boundaries your life becomes
smaller and smaller yeah that happens to
people with panic it I think it well it
happens just people in general and I
think it's one of the reasons why people
fall into panic is because they don't
have enough experience with stressful
situations to the point where they could
just relax and just let it happen and
that that's one of the things that I one
of the reasons why I think martial arts
training is very good for people not
just for the self-defense aspect of it
but for the aspect of just dealing with
stressful situations on a regular basis
to the point where you're very
comfortable with them and then you
realize that the consequences of this is
it's not really as bad as you think it
is like most people are terrified of
physical confrontation but when you have
physical confrontation on a regular
basis especially through my favorite
which is jujitsu training because
there's no striking so you don't get hit
in the head you're not worried about
brain damage or any of that stuff it's
just basically grappling but that
through the continual process of testing
yourself and stress and regular life
stresses sort of become diminished most
of what people do is what we're doing
right now most of what people do is sit
down but is that because they don't feel
like running around because some people
like people who exercise
generally you have to put in a little
bit of effort to make yourself go
exercise but a lot of people who are
overweight and sick don't have enough
energy to do that I don't know about
that some of them may be but I think
some of them just don't have discipline
there's an issue with that as well
there's also an issue with momentum
you're not used to doing it it's not a
part of your life it's not something
you're accustomed to pushing yourself
there's been many many many many many
many many days where I didn't want to
work out I just didn't feel like I had
the energy and I just forced myself and
I think there's very few people out
there that know how to force themselves
that's a learn yeah it's a learned skill
yeah that that kind of discipline and
focus you have to have like real rigid
requirements of yourself where you don't
allow yourself to back out of things and
you don't allow yourself to slack off
and I don't think people put those kind
of requirements on themselves as if it's
it is a daily principle of life like
what you must get done you know you must
brush your teeth and exercise for 45
minutes and if you did that I think
you'd be healthier and happier and your
body would perform more smoothly and you
if you require your body to do things
like that I think it rises to the
occasion there are very few people that
have that kind of discipline so because
of that they come up with excuses and
excuses are a giant part of the problem
it's not simply a physical health issue
there's also mental aspects of it and
disciplines a big one I just know way
too many people who are weak mentally
and I can't I can't just chalk it off to
only you know their physical though the
way they physically feel because I felt
like a hundred times and then I worked
out and then I felt way better yeah just
it's just a fact of life that's real you
know you just can't and I people don't
know how to do that it's not and if
you're used to doing this getting your
car sit down drive to the office sit
down go to the lunch sit down you know
go to the board meeting sit down get in
your car on the way home sit down get
home in front of the TV sit down then go
to the gym off they don't have any
energy you know their body's not the
body's like I don't know
me to do this and I don't believe that I
don't believe that I think it's it's a
lot of it is the the mindset stress it
seems to follow us in every turn in life
through timeless wisdom we could learn
to transform stress into a positive
energy that inspires personal
fulfillment and heightened productivity
the same stress that pummels us into
anxiety has the potential to increase
the value of life physically emotionally
and spiritually stress can break us or
strengthen us an athlete grows in speed
and strength through enduring stress for
example when lifting weights the greater
the resistance the stronger the
weightlifter becomes however if not
balanced properly the stress of the
weight could injure your back or damaged
your muscles properly managed even the
stress of taking exams in school can be
an impetus to serious study the queen of
gems the precious diamond is nothing but
common cold that with the help of
nature's wisdom has been transformed
under extreme pressure and gold the king
of metals is purified by blazing fire
now I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best like 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
this video you have to do something so
pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets you can get them for free
check the link in the description below
alright here we go question number one
how can you allow less stress into your
life number two how will you better deal
with the stress you allow in and then
three who can you share with when you
feel stressed and overwhelmed and if you
are doing the best life 30 challenge
with me give me a hashtag best live 30
in the comments below so I can celebrate
with you this is why it's so important
that you love what you do
success is painful it's a lot of work a
lot of stress a lot of failure a lot of
rejection but the thing that gets you
through it is you love what you do you
love the process you love the work you
love the growth if you don't love the
work you do you will give up because it
will just become too painful to keep
going so at the Whole Foods this morning
when I went to go get my bulletproof
coffee I ran into a friend of mine
they're not trying to find the mine who
I told about my tour in December before
I left and she was super excited and I
hadn't connected with her since I got
back I went on this 3-month 90-day 23
City tour across the US and it was
amazing happenstance to meet her at the
Whole Foods this morning and she said
house a tour what was the best part of
it and I said breaking my neck
two-thirds of the way through I broke my
neck I broke my neck in two spots I
compressed my spine I had a concussion
had they get staples in my head all of
it
she said breaking your neck that's the
best part of your torille that's a
really positive outlook like it's not
just a positive outlook it's the best
like it actually was the best part
because it really got the test like why
this sounds crazy but this is it this is
this is the process it's the mindset
shift I want you guys to make that you
do difficult things you love difficult
things you don't want it to be easy easy
means you're inside your comfort zone
easy means you're not pushing up against
any barriers you don't want to be easy
stop getting these easy small tiny wings
that you can snack on you do difficult
things you love taking on amazing huge
things that's who you are that's what
you do and this was a chance for me to
grow and help cement that for myself if
you want to join the best like 30
challenge for free click the link right
here below me or if you want more videos
to overcome stress check out the
playlist right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there